there is an army of firefighters now
engaged in this battle even these young
men and women who dream of careers as
firefighters have volunteered to join
the effort it is a relentless and
exhausting task as one shift rolls out
to take on the fire in the hills above
Los Angeles and other returns for some
rest captain Jason Lawrence has just
clocked up the 50th hour of his shift
and the hours ahead are expected to
bring winds that could wreak more havoc
so with the strong winds you know they
can carry embers you know pretty far
away so you know we can get spot fires
across the line and stuff like that so
you know wind creates its own weather as
well and so you know dealing with the
wind it's it's very tough aspect of the
job it does take its toll you know you
you know you're tired on the fire line
but you know you are saving lives you're
also you know trying to protect the
public as well
it's impossible to know how many homes
they've saved but a few were beyond help
we were here 24 hours ago when it looked
like firefighters had saved this house
but the intensity of the flames so
fierce that as you can see it is gutted
one floor and caused another to
completely collapse this is what one
family will return home to one of the
wealthiest neighborhoods in America
remains deserted even though the smokes
cleared the evacuation orders stay in
place with the prospect of more fires I
know you are frustrated I know you are
impatient I know you really want to go
home so do our first responders they
know what they are doing they have
looked at the science they have looked
at the winds they have looked at the
maps they are eager to let you go back
they let folks go back as soon as
possible last week in the Palisades fire
they will let you go back as soon as it
is safe and practicably possible it's
the same story hundreds of miles to the
north in wine country tens of thousands
of people told to stay away crews trying
to get ahead of the fire before the
winds arrived dozens of buildings have
burned here Californians know all too
well what these fires can do
is calm now but they've been warned the
worst might yet be to come Gregg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles